hey everybody welcome to the podcast if
there was anyone who does not need
an introduction today it's today's guest
matthew mcconaughey
everybody knows who this guy is he was
an absolute delight
uh this is an incredible conversation he
was so
generous and warm and open i'm so
excited for you
to hear it before we get into it please
hit that subscribe button hit that
notification bell
and pick up matthew's new book green
lights
it's an incredible read it will not
disappoint
and neither does this conversation so
without further ado
this is me and matthew mcconaughey all
right all right all right
[Music]
thank you so much for doing this you
ready to rock
let's roll so our point of
introduction or inflection was our
mutual friend dan buettner
who pleasantly uh introduced us
and we were meant to go on this
backpacking trip in utah like this
ultralight backpacking trip that got
cancelled because of covid so i was i
was
looking forward to meeting you in person
but that's gonna have to wait for
another day
well our good man dan is a good curator
of
uh of people with with like the
challenging minds
you know you know my nickname is gh no
what does that mean
generally uh heroic and i don't mean
just sometimes i mean from four
dimensions and 360 view whichever view
you want to take
he's generally heroic where did you
first meet him
i met him um we were over i think in uh
in europe at a at a got a google weekend
a google getaway he was one of the
speakers and
uh he was the uh first speaker i believe
and of the day of that so said day and
what he had to say i remember listening
to him just going
that guy's got the greatest job in the
world yeah he goes around
studying longevity and happiness and
people and culture
and so i chased him down um and made
sure i got his eyeliner and shook his
hand and met him and talked to him about
some things and uh
he continued uh uh to call me bradley
cooper and then i think you know
kind of went up and flirted with my wife
and called her mrs cooper
that sounds like dan she's still
generally heroic and now he's rehabbing
his rehabilitation did you see his
latest fall
i did i did i'm gonna go up and and
visit him up in santa barbara
in a week or so i told him i said a
pothole in the middle of the street in
minnesota it just doesn't fit the meter
of a
generally heroic dan button wreck for
all the stuff that that guy has done
riding his bike across saudi arabia and
everything for him to get
knocked down that way but amen happens
to the best of us but i reached out to
him
and i was like what should i ask matthew
that is
you know mainly not googleable and he
said
some people think that matthew is is
heroic in a lot of areas
acting fatherhood ambassadorship
scholarship
others think he's just generally heroic
yeah comments so my so my boomerang came
back yeah
oh that's all him he's he's the purely
gh one
um he just he calls me many nicknames
one of them professor i think because
i'm a professor of ut
um no he's the generally heroic one
uh more so than me so your question
being what how am i generally heroic or
how do you respond to that can you take
that compliment how does that land for
you
um well i've always i've enjoyed trying
to
entertain what the definition of a hero
is all through
through life i mean you know you've got
the
uh what's always been said as they talk
about you know
are men and women who go off to defend
to defend the country or
the true heroes and then you say there's
heroes every day
that that do good deeds i don't know if
that's
heroic um i'll say this on on on any
kind of heroism whatever your definition
is whatever anyone's definition is
um when i got
fame and success and started a uh
um a foundation that we have it just
keep living the map school foundation
that's doing very well
i didn't i chose to do that now whether
that's heroic i don't think it's heroic
but what i'm leaning into is this
some people say it's a responsibility
once you have success you
it's your responsibility i don't think
that's true i think it's a personal
choice just it's like
uh um you know every day the choices
we make uh uh i think should be very
selfish i don't think we make good
choices for anybody unless it's personal
so i don't i don't know about the heroic
i wouldn't i would consider myself
a a hero um
i'm i've been fortunate to to and had an
innate ability
and work my backside off to be at least
pretty damn good at some things
still got some things in the debit
section uh i will say this my favorite
job in the world has been a father
i don't know being a good father is a
heroic job
he's just being a good father so i don't
know i don't know what to do with the
hero comment coming back from
right maybe it all depends on how you
define it how broadly or how
strictly i suppose but more a
conversation around
you know how to be a man of character i
suppose
man of character yeah we can talk about
that until
all all day long you know and even that
is not a responsibility but a choice
you know the only thing i ever knew i
wanted to be was to be a father
in my life and then i've also learned
now that okay well
just because you helped make a child
doesn't mean you're you did the work of
a father
father's is fatherhood is a verb um
as in life is a verb these character
choices we make
uh choices we make every day are our you
know
compounded assets for our future or not
um
i am i have been blessed with a long
view
of of life of realizing early on that
in investments in ourselves today can
tee up
roi and our future can buy us green
lights in our future the choices we make
today are compounding assets of our
future and can tie us up
for success since the title of the book
green lights i know i know for a fact we
can engineer green lights in our life i
also know for a fact that i've been damn
fortunate had some just
on my lap but choices of character are
long-term choices
that deal with delayed gratification
yeah i remember something that dan told
me a while back
which was when he was when he was early
in his career
and thinking about what he wanted to do
and who he wanted to be
he was spending time working for george
plimpton at the paris review
and he would go to these fancy you know
upper east side
uh parties with all these mucky mucks
and george although he was respected
wasn't necessarily a man of means but he
had made this decision to live this life
of
adventure and when they would go to
these parties all these people would
gravitate
around george because he was the one
with the stories
and that's what made dan inspired to
live the kind of amazing life of
adventure that that he's lived
and i see a lot of that in you i mean
we're going to talk about the book but
these pivots that you've made the
wanderlust that kind of infuses
your life and these moments where
you know by dint of a wet dream or some
kind of epiphany that you would have or
being stuck
you would always know this is the time
where i need to kind of
um do my walk about so i'm interested in
how that kind of plays into
the fabric of of your life and how you
prioritize it
well look i think you know
those hints angels of truth are around
us all the time it's just
we don't always notice them you know
they're there
but we don't notice them and it's
understandable but a high frequency life
man a lot of noise coming in on all of
us
so i have learned early on to listen to
that spider sense in me that says
you need to go get away mcconaughey you
need to go spend some time with yourself
open up the autobahn between your head
and your heart
because right now it's a bit of a
one-way gravel
you know dirt road for you and
you know your heart your heart and your
mind aren't really uh in sync as much in
sync as they should be and then
questioning what matters i've always
questioned since i was 14 one of the
things with writing the book my diary
entries when i was 14 were about this
similar or about similar
topics that i'm still interested in
today at 50. i've had a pretty good
threshold
for when i do get that spider sense to
say oh you need to get out of here
mcconaughey you need to leave
what you're in so you can get outside
and have a clear view
you need to leave where you are right
now and find out
what what do i find out when i go away
uh memory catches up
oh demarcations between events that
maybe i was handling
and i'm good at handling events uh just
being being in the middle of it going
press
you know let's do this pile it on me
i'll be a horse i'll get through it but
i didn't notice what had happened to me
like for instance when i got famous i
didn't notice what that was until i got
the hell out of
dodge and went on a 22 day walk about
with myself in peru
then i was like oh that's what happened
oh
that's what that event or circumstance
or
run in with that person was about
because they were all on top of each
other at the time
i wasn't able to separate things that
were going on too much frequency
um so i have gone away
many times on my own i've learned to
enjoy the solitude not necessarily
enjoying my company in the solitude
which usually the first 12 days
i do not enjoy my company i'm shaking
demons off my back feeling regret
lost confused trying to figure stuff out
and usually around day 12 or day 13
i'll have a breakthrough um and it's
usually it's that breakthrough where
all right come on hey since you're the
only guy i'm stuck with and i can't get
rid of
which is each of us for ourselves what
are we going to forgive and what are we
going to say i'm not
not putting up with anymore figure those
two out
shake hands with myself and wake up the
next morning and then those trips are
wonderful then i'm present
then i'm singing a song then wisdom's
landing on me
then i'm hearing those angels and those
butterflies of truth that land and you
go
bam this is on me i'm hearing it now how
do i personalize it
this truth and ask myself and answer the
question why it's coming to me
how do i preserve it have the patience
to preserve it
and then when i leave those trips the
big fun challenge is how do i take that
truth
the solitary truth back into the masses
back into the stadium
of life and ride that bull that rodeo of
life and remember
trust that this truth that crossed me
that found me
while i was in solitude is true
now then and forever wherever i am
right that's the hard part it's it it
strikes me as almost
this uh impulse for self-preservation or
self-defense like there's it takes a
certain level of
awareness as an individual to recognize
those moments even if they're visited
upon all of us and
you're somebody you know the fact that
you've been journaling consistently
from you know way back from an early age
tells me
that you're an introspective person by
nature
i'm not sure where that came from maybe
you have an answer to that
but then you go on these adventures
that are about self-defense
self-preservation reinvention
reflection and then the trick the hard
part is bringing it back and not letting
it evaporate but
but taking you know having being able to
distill whatever wisdom comes to you
about the experience itself but more
importantly what you learn about
your own self and then trying to exude
that to
imbue it and live your life in
accordance in accordance
yes and again you're right that the
initial reaction to leave and go into
solitude is a defense mechanism is a
survival mechanism
is a whoa whoa whoa i'm i'm not feeling
grounded
here uh mentally spiritually uh so i
need to i don't know what the answer is
but i just know i got to get out of here
where i can hear myself think i know i
got to get out of here where i can
be in a place where i can receive some
of the truth um
then yeah that fun challenge of bringing
it back
and yes not let it be stripped away
which it eventually does and it gets
tripped away
but even better sometimes bring it back
and play offense with it
like go i'm not just coming back going
like can i hold on to it i want to put
it into action
uh i want i want to you know it's why
i'm such a slow reader
if i read you know one of my favorite
writings is emerson's essay on
self-reliant
well i mean that take that that that
essay which is about 20 pages long took
me two years to read
because it's good though the first
paragraph i'm like whoa
i got to take that and see if i can
apply that in life and see what the
reverb of life is back to me if i'm
looking through that lens
which takes me a couple of months before
i can come back and read the next
paragraph
that's the fun stuff i like to read or
the fun things that
wisdom will come to me in solitude that
i want to take back into society
and you're right it strips away you look
up and you go oh i'm falling back into
some old habits i forgot that i gotta go
calibrate i gotta go back to school i
gotta go break a sweat i need to go away
again
i need to go revisit my diary and look
at what i was doing when i was
satisfied when i was successful when i
was happy with myself my relationships
were good when i did have that autobond
between the mind and the heart
and because i'm in a rut again so i need
to go back and i found clues
in my diaries of when i was happy as to
what i was doing oh who was i hanging
out with
what was i drinking where was i going
how much sleep was i getting
oh i see now in my life i'm in this bit
of a rut
i'm complacent with some of those things
i'm doing some things that are that are
not feeding myself and so i need to go
back so some of those diaries have been
good little maps for me
to go back and dissect when i felt
successful and happy
rather than just go dissect failures
which is more of our
our habits i think do you find it more
difficult
to pull the trigger or pull the rip cord
and
and and you know split when things are
going well or when things are
challenging like as you progress through
life
and you have more responsibilities and
more
abundance in your life it's gotta be
harder to say i'm gonna i'm gonna walk
away from this
and go try something else it's different
when you're all of
whatever you were 23 24 and you were
living in an airstream
yeah and having three children and a
general life family makes that a little
harder too
um but yeah more difficult when things
are going
well because i don't know about you but
me when things are going well i
inevitably feel like oh well this is the
mean
this is how it's supposed to be this is
how it is i've got it figured out
this way there's no reason for it ever
to dip below this which of course it
always does
um and then i gotta go off again but i
have
uh you know part of the inspiration for
going away to go write this book was a
bit was
was that i needed a trip away and not
only my wife knew i needed it yeah
she gave me a kick in the backside and
she'll come to me and tell me
you need to get out of here for a while
go off
you know go off don't come and then i'll
call you know and she'll like don't even
call of course what's that mean of
course i'm calling now right
much quicker than if she said make sure
you call because i don't like to be told
what to do um but i'll go away and like
with this she goes don't come back to
you got something however long that
takes we're good i got the kiddos here
go it was a gift she gave me
um i was able to go away on these
walkabouts without having to look over
my shoulder and go
ugh am i building a debit right now
because when i go back am i going to
have to do a whole
lot of extra work to catch back up for
what i miss she's never been
uh someone who made me feel like okay
well now you've been away
now you need to double up on all your
duties it was always like she pushes me
out the door and she did with this book
that's uh that's amazing you definitely
married the right one
for that yeah well the this as the story
goes
and i don't know how much of this is
apocryphal versus true
you you took off with your journals you
went to the desert
for something like 52 days i read
somewhere that
that uh you did it without electricity
but then in the book you at the end of
the book you kind of
you were in a a couple different places
right like i'm envisioning you with a
typewriter like if you don't have
electricity how are you writing this
book
well i started off with that election
the first 12 days with that electricity
um and i took a generator so i could
plug in my
laptop um and that was just
you know i wanted to go someplace where
i didn't
email i shut down my account i want to
go somewhere with no
phone signal to where only you know 6
p.m each night there's a certain
hill about a half a mile away that i
would hike to the top and make the call
to check on the family and that was it
other than that no incoming calls no
incoming emails no outgoing
i needed to be stripped out of the
necessities to go say
how can i best go off solitude with me
and me of my last 50 years
um without any outside invitations
and so that was the first 12 days and i
must say i went into
it it was intimidating number one to go
i thought looking back
at 50 years of my life i was going to be
embarrassed i thought there were things
i knew there were things i'm going to be
ashamed about
there were places i was going to go you
arrogant little prick what were you
thinking um
and what happened is most of the things
that i thought i would be embarrassed
about
i ended up laughing at most of the
things i thought i'd be ashamed about
i'd ended up forgiving myself or or
noticed i already had forgiven myself
for and the parts where i was arrogant
i laughed at but was also like well good
on you for thinking you knew it all
at that point because following those
points
in my diaries where i would be so
self-confident and all-knowing
i always very soon stepped in [ __ ] in my
life
going based off like i am i i absolutely
know it and i was happy that at least i
had the confidence to think i
had it all figured out and then as life
dealt me cards found out i didn't
um i went away thinking that these
diaries are going to be much more
academic and
i remember the first four days sort of
trying to force it into an academia mind
and all of a sudden i stopped and i
remember i stopped when i said look
all right you haven't even looked at
these things just read each page
and see what it is see what it lends
itself to be
and let's just stack up see if some
categories show up
and what happened after about 10 days
was i had these seven stacks
it was a stack full of stories it was a
stack full of people
stacked full of places a stack full of
prescribes
a stack full of poems prayers and a
whole bunch of bumper stickers
so those were my categories and then i
said okay
we have some semblance here some
structure of something now what is all
this
and that was actually that what i just
ripped off was my original title hmm
stories people places prescribes points
prayers and a whole bunch of bumper
stickers
not a bad title but i then said
now let's read through all these and see
if something another central theme
or column reveals itself and that's
where the title green lights came from
um i noticed uh that there were
successes in my life that engineered i
noticed there were successes that i got
just playing good fortune and
landed in my lap i noticed that
in certain ways red and yellow lights in
my life crisis
and hardships i
immediately i believed while i was in
them that there was a lesson to be
learned in a green light
asset within them not knowing when i
would it would be revealed to me but
trusting
just to stick with it stick with the
hardship endure it
and there's a le there's a there's a
green light in it i noticed that some
things that i thought like my father
passing how could that be a green light
that's an absolute red light well i
keep reading my diaries ten years later
i'm understanding how
the values and incentive that he taught
me i wouldn't have enacted them
in my own life if he'd have still been
alive because i would have relied on him
being there
to have my back so his passing away
actually gave me a kick in the backside
to
look the world in the eye and have more
courage to go chase down who i want to
be
and be myself so some of the
some of the hardships that i had
revealed green light some of the
hardships of that i suppose have not
revealed their green lights yet and may
not reveal themselves and
they may only reveal themselves to my
great grandkids i don't know but
eventually
the theme of the book is that all the
red and yellows do eventually turn green
and i believe that
yeah so the narrative always comes back
to this idea of green lights
and i mean first of all i should say
like i i finished the book this morning
i
i loved it to echo what our other mutual
friend ryan holiday said i think he said
something like
i knew it was going to be a good book i
didn't know it was going to be this good
like you did an amazing job with this
book
it has this really um
you know very mcconaughey-esque touch to
it like it's
it's your book through and through but
it also reminded me of kind of the beat
poets it has that type of aesthetic and
it's this
kind of patchwork of you know stories
from your life
in a relatively traditional kind of
memoir narrative but
interspersed with your poetry and always
with these
kind of life lessons and takeaways that
are just
unbelievably wise and i would look at
these and i would i would wonder like
how old was he when he wrote this stuff
i mean when you went back and looked at
your journals were you surprised at
the wisdom of some of the things that
you said when you were younger was there
anything that stuck out that you didn't
expect
um obviously the earlier
diary entries were whys
why what where when hows it was the
questions there was a question mark
after everything so i was always seeking
the questions
as i evolved and got older i started to
answer some of those questions
and could sum them up in a wisdom bomb
or an aphorism or a bumper sticker right
but it didn't lead to any fewer
questions
my questions evolved i think but as i
said earlier
what i was looking what i was at the
questions i was asking at 14
about existence and who am i and what's
what matters and what's life about
how the world works who am i in this
world i still question those
but to interrupt you quickly there it is
unusual for a 14 year old to be asking
those kinds of questions
so i'm curious like where do you think
that comes from in you
i don't know you know i don't know how
to answer that because
we weren't raised as a very
introspective family we always have our
prayer and gratitude as a family we were
raised as consistent extroverts
i mean like i wasn't allowed to watch tv
or read
because my mom would say why
read about or watch somebody do
something that you can go do yourself
get outside
uh-huh as always go go to do it go
experience it
so you know i don't know where my my
family my mom wasn't really a writer my
dad wasn't
um i mean i was always though early on
the inquisitor of the family the
interrogator the one who wasn't
satisfied with mom and dad just going
because we said so
i'll go well let's get underneath this
that's why i was going to be a lawyer i
was they were like
dude you matthew the youngest one you
debate things and
question things to the nth degree and
it's exhausting at times so i was always
sort of wanting to get to the underbelly
of the meaning of things
um at a very early age i don't know
where that came from but that's just
kind of i think always been who i am
um yeah in reading about
growing up with your dad i mean i i just
i was thinking
most people who have had an experience
like that
would be you know doing a lot of therapy
and harboring a lot of resentments
but you really have a lot of peace
around it
and a lot of love a lot of honor a lot
of love
that's the word you know i i um
if you look at the stories and i open up
with a wild story about a
monumental fight that my mom and dad had
which got bloody
but ended up with him making love on the
floor uh-huh i always when people ask me
about the love of my family or
the love that i have my parents had for
me and that my mom and dad had for each
other
i always have told these stories
of discipline that also that involves
some form of violence
or corporal punishment and i'm on this
book tour i've been wondering why
because when i tell you this story you
see me light up
and people go like on paper i've got my
hand over my mouth going
oh my gosh call child protection
services and yes matthew mccain you must
have been in therapy since then
to deal with this trauma and i'm like no
so when i tell the story though
people get very you see the humanity and
the love that i have for them and i
think
the reason i tell those stories is
because
they were the biggest test to defeat the
bubble of love that we were surrounded
with but they never had a chance of
beating it
and so i tell those stories because
there's like a lightning rod of like oh
this is trauma oh this is violent oh
this is a problem oh this is where it
all falls apart
but it actually never had a chance
i mean my mom and dad divorced twice
married three times
the two divorces are that lightning rod
trying to puncture that
bubble of love ended in three marriages
got married more than they got
us getting punished i earned every time
everything i got punished for and i look
back and i go
well you got your first butt whooping
for not answering to your name you're
second for saying i
can't you're third for saying i hate you
to your brother and your fourth for
lying
well i'm gonna go back and do the math
that's four pretty doggone good reasons
to get your butt whooped
always answered to your name know you're
having trouble
doing something instead of that you
can't do it
don't hate and don't lie i mean like
there were values
instilled in those and every time i did
it i remember
not the butt whooping but the value that
i don't say that word
c-a-n-t you know i don't i don't hate
um i do go no it's not matt's matthew
you know
i do my best to tell the truth and not
lie
you know so those are good those were
good lessons that were ingrained in us
and i think that's why i tell those as
love stories
even though like i say on paper you
agree or disagree with the form of
punishment
that's what was being instilled in me
and that's what i took from it even then
you know when my mom taught me to swim
and threw me in the river and here we
come on a waterfall that if i go off
that i'm not gonna die but i'm gonna
i'm gonna break a bone or two and she
walks along the bank with her arms
crossed going
swim swim swim when i
finally put my head down and saw that
waterfall coming and swam to the bank
i was scared but i wasn't mad i was
immediately
proud and and like
you know in shock but was immediately
proud because i was like
mama's right she was right it was time
for me to swim yeah there's
there's so many lessons in that it's an
extreme example of something that i
think has been eroded in our culture
in this time of you know participation
trophies where
you know we're coddling our kids to such
an extent that
we're depriving them of you know some of
those rough and tumble moments where
they get their knees skinned so that
they can learn these lessons
you know i don't know about the extreme
of your your examples but
at least letting kids fail and fall
and get into trouble and figure out you
know
where their compass lies let them go
negotiate
i mean i agree with you i think in some
in some ways we we can and do
deprive our children of understanding
how to go negotiate a situation i i've
been looking at like this it's like
a tree limb a child's not afraid of
heights until they fall
well before they've fallen it's like all
right see them on that tree and you go
they fell from there i mean it's gonna
hurt but
i'm not gonna you know have to go to the
hospital i think i'll let them keep
climbing there
you know let them go negotiate that and
maybe they make it or maybe they fall
well then it gets up higher and they're
certainly going man if they fell from
there this could be
really really painful i think now's the
time to go hey
hey come on down a little bit you know
what i mean it's like what level limb do
we let them go out and then we should i
think a lot of society
raise the level of that limb a little
bit to let our kids go
yeah you're going to get bumped and
bruised there buddy you're going to skin
the knees
go ahead and wear those knees out in
your jeans and or fall from that limb
and go
yep you see that happens yeah
if you don't pay attention so i yeah i
would say
i'm not you know i don't think we should
say the the level of the
the height of the limb that my parents
sort of let us walk out on
needs to be the mean for everybody but
there was great value in those
in those lessons and we never were
abused
we never were injured it hurt
blood was drawn but we were never
injured
there's a difference between hurt and
injury and we were never you know so and
we were never abused and again
the love was never in question and being
reared in the
kind of shadow of this outlaw logic
there was a fair amount of
acting out on your part but it was kind
of healthy teenager
stuff like you weren't taking it too
you know to such an extent that you were
getting into big time trouble
no i number one i was pretty good with
getting away with stuff because i had
two older brothers
who as they say paved a wide highway for
me
um and you know my brothers would jack
with me because they were like you
little
mama's boy the golden boy and i remind
them well i got away with stuff better
than y'all did too because i learned
that at the same time i was you know a
bit of a hell raiser but it was all sort
of good
what it wasn't it wasn't too gnarly of
stuff i mean i
you know i never really got into drugs i
didn't harm other people i got away with
some things that
you know wouldn't be prescriptive for
everyone to get away with but
i also say this and someone asked me the
other day do you believe
uh you know you were you were raised as
i see in the book matthew with a certain
amount of fear of your
father and mother you still believe in
the value of that and my answer is
yeah so how do you translate that as a
parent to three kids now
yeah well differently than my mom and
dad did yeah
i would think so i don't choose to and
i'm not judging how they did it
um again yeah i write about this in the
book my parents
also their reasoning trust me i went to
them before and said would you please
ground me
and they were like no i go why and i go
because that would be taking your time
away from you and your time is valuable
now bend over we're going to get this
over with and then it's over
glad that happened that way that's not
how i choose to raise my children
right now um i'm trying to
camilla aren't trying to teach our kids
values we do talk we do not say because
i said so as much as
my parents did or most of our parents
probably did we do try to explain things
we try to uh
um you know we had an instance the other
night you know the youngest one was was
was getting sleepy and popped off and
and you know disrespected his mother
just by like walking away from the
middle thing like
now look i'm tired camille's tired it's
a late night we've been out
all day with the kids what do you want
to do you kind of want to let it slide
and just go to bed and let them go to
sleep
no no we're building a debit we've got
to gather up the energy and sit down
with our son and go
do you understand why that's not
allowable
this is your mother all right she works
her butt off we work our butt off to
give you a house to give you a meal to
raise you
and nudge you to be the young man
that you can be and you have to have
respect and what you just did was
disrespectful and if you're
disrespecting her you're disrespecting
yourself
and you do not have the right to talk to
your mother like that
it's a hell of a lot easier for your mom
and i to let it slide and just let you
go to bed
with that punk move you just pulled but
we're going to stay up and we're going
to handle this right now until you
understand
why that's disrespectful why it's mean
and why it's ugly
and why you're out of line and why if
you continue to do that
the days will just not be as fun for you
um and it took a while it was a very
stubborn son that i was talking to
went on for over an hour and a half and
finally he understood it and the fact
that we gave that amount of time
to say no you're not going to bed yet no
we're not going to bed until you get
it i mean yeah just sitting there
spending the time and your child going
like
geez mom and dad are still here an hour
and a half later and they're not letting
me off the hook
okay i get it so and then you know the
challenge becomes how do you have them
how can they remember that so they don't
become repeat offenders so quick
you know right after yeah he'll remember
that and i think you know what you said
earlier about
asking your mom to please ground you
like the child
wants those boundaries and they know
that you're coming to them
from a place of love even if it's hard
and concerning
well on the fear thing again i know
that there's a lot of things i was faced
with temptation to a lot of things grow
up
growing up that i knew i shouldn't do
that i did not do for fear of the
consequences
so fear definitely kept me from doing
things because i'm like i measured it
wait a minute
if we go egg that car and do that and
man and pop find out about that oh my
gosh that's going to be hell okay
no risk reward i'm out you know there's
just certain things that said it's not
it's not worth it
and i had certain friends that didn't
have the consequences to deal with that
i would have had to
deal with that did go do it and got away
with all kinds of stuff and
some of them didn't ever really uh uh
some of them turned out to be you know
uh
crappy dudes but there was also like
you're
it was almost like your dad wanted you
to do some of these things as long as
you told him the truth
it wasn't the offense that offended him
it was you
lying about it like as long as you were
honest with him and you got away with it
it was almost an attaboy from him
in a way and that was part of the
initiation of mandate he wouldn't let us
know that
what you just said but that is what he
was looking for
so there's a story in there about me
stealing a pizza one night with but with
the buddy of mine bud
junker and the i
got home my dad's on the phone with mr
felker
the father of the guy that i was out
with and we stole the pizza
walked out on the pizza from pizza hut
and you know you get older you come home
and you've stolen a pizza and your dad
goes did you pay for that pizza
you should know right now that he knows
you didn't i mean
but of course at that age i'm like well
no i mean i think so dad i mean we we
well the girl had recognized bud called
his dad and said hey it was my table
they walked out on the pizza and my dad
was just looking for me to go
yeah we stole the pizza and he'd have
gone gosh
damn me son i've stolen a lot of pizzas
in my life
listen next time get away with it better
but thank you for telling me
what you did now gosh damn it get your
ass in bed right
watch it well i didn't i groveled i
defended myself i tried to weasel my
way out of it he gave me three four
chances to tell him
yes and i dug myself such a hole
that i'm shivering there with the damn p
spot in my genes and
fright not from him but at my own
cowardice right and i remember i finally
asked gave me one last chance just tell
me did you know you were going to steal
that pizza
and i went with no sir and he basically
backhanded me
and i crumbled to the floor in the
corner not from the backhand but because
my
lactic acid coward hypocritical legs
were numb under me from being such a
weasel and not being able to just admit
yes i did and that's what broke his
heart
and i was scared because i saw i was
breaking my dad's heart right in front
of me because all he wanted me to do is
what you said just tell me son just tell
me the truth don't lie to me about
stealing a damn pizza man
it's not about to steal the pizza it's
about owning up to what you did and
telling your father the truth
and that i remember the tears on my face
were seeing my dad heartbroken and
heartbroken and knowing that i let him
down
well it's just one of many rites of
passage that he
puts you through and the book is you
know
makes it very clear how important these
rites of passage are
in your you know evolution as a human
being
so much so that it seems to me that
these
um walkabout adventures that you go on
later are your way of creating
additional rites of passage
when you know we live in a culture where
we're bereft of those like
most people don't grow up with any kind
of meaningful rights of passage and
that's something that we're hardwired to
need we have to test ourselves or we
need to be tested by somebody else and
if we're not getting that we have to put
ourselves in that position
yes need resistance to find structure to
create
form and you know for me
later in life i get successful i'm
famous
you know too many options could make a
tyrant of any of us
and when the world's saying yes well
that's where the devil lives and all the
yes is not the nose
and i needed to go wait a minute is this
what really matters i have that line in
the book but
when you can ask yourself if you want to
before you do
well when you're getting all these
things for the first time in your life
and everything the world's a big green
light and everything's yes
i wanted to go away and see wait a
minute are these green lights that are
plugged into a battery or are they
eternal
you know solar powered green lights well
i'm getting a lot of them that i was
like oh these are all kind of
plugged into a battery they're they're
impermanent they're just kind of for now
they're they're they're kind of a fad
they're not really think they're stops
not stays
and so i need to go away create that
resistance
put myself into discomfort go without
things sort of fast
um from not just food or drink but fast
from attention
fast from fame fast from uh all the
yeses
that are coming to to me in the world
and get some discernment again as i said
earlier let my memory catch up who the
heck am i what really matters
what i give at them about what was that
moment is that a real moment or was that
just part of the
was i just part of the machine you know
and so to disseminate
and have and and discriminate make some
choices for myself again that's why
i needed those walkabouts and still do
right i mean when you're
you talk about you're kind of hitting
your stride
you're making bank you're in all these
movies you move into the chateau
you're wearing leather pants you're
hitting the clock it's all
it's all happening i mean most people
would just ride that out
and just more more and more when am i
going to get the house up in the hills
and
just continue to double down for as long
as
you know the industry would allow them
to do so until you're 27 years old that
seems to be the going age of all the
uh the great rock and rollers they make
it to 27 and then they go
yeah and they all all at the chateau too
[Laughter]
god bless the chateau boy they they
promote a little bit of mischief
thank goodness and i gave myself some
license there i said you know what i'm
going to test this out
i'm going to test out my
threshold of hedonism i'm going to i
don't want to be harmful i don't want to
be mean i don't i don't want to be
you know mean anyone else or myself at
the same time i'm gonna give myself
a saturday night pov for
for some time and i did it for a couple
of years um
and then i just noticed that okay this
feels revolutionary not evolutionary
this feels like a stop
not a stay this indulgence an
option to indulge is not i'm not really
feeling
an ascension in my life i'm cool with
where it is i'm not griping about it i'm
enjoying it
and i'd be silly if i didn't but i'm not
really feeling a build
an ascension in my life and i want to
feel build
um so i decided to get out of there
and go away so i knew at that time
it was that that was a stop and not a
stay i also
you know during that time at the end of
that time really started to question
my belief in in god and stuff and so i
remember saying you know
okay you're a believer but why and is
your belief
is your sense of belief matthew your
fatalistic sense of belief that it's all
fake is it is is that it
you using that as an excuse almost in
ways in your life to let yourself
off the hook and i remember going well
let's just
put two hands on the wheel of
self-determination here and let's be our
own judge and jury
matthew and let's call it out and not
rely on hey
you know you know what if you know it's
all been written
and so i went through a very i would
call it an agnostic time and as i said
in the book it wasn't as much of a time
where i
disbelieve god it was a time where i
said you need to hold yourself more
accountable
matt you need to have both hands on your
wheel where you're going because you're
letting yourself slide
on just about a lot of stuff and
i want to go test that out i want to
hold you i want to hold you more
accountable matthew so i want to hold
myself
more accountable and um went through a
couple of years of that it was a very
good exercise
and my relationship with god i believe
my belief is that god was smiling and
going yeah good honor
way to grab a hold of the wheel because
i didn't because yeah you do have free
will and
and and i don't i and it didn't make me
think that anything's going to change
after this life
but it did make me say hey while i'm in
it remember that i've got freedom of
choice and hold myself more responsible
for my choices well let's let's dig a
little bit deeper into the
the faith conversation um because i
think that that
that green lights really is a spiritual
book i mean just on the subject of
green lights itself there's this idea
that you
can catch them by virtue of skill intent
endurance resilience discipline hard
work all of these things
but the flip side of that coin is this
idea that you talked about earlier like
engineering them and that's about
frequency that's about intuition
fate like you just said it's about
finding your way into the zone and it's
about how you
comport yourself in the world so you
become a magnet for good things as
opposed to somebody who's
chasing them yeah
um look i say in there in the book i'm
pretty sure the world can
at times i'm pretty sure the world's
conspiring to make me happy uh
and then what i mean by that is someone
asked me this the other day what do you
what do you your measures of trust
where they come from and how do you
and how do you have that with people
here in my answer
which i never answered before until i
was asked that was
i come into this conversation just
meeting you and you have 100 of my trust
until you disprove me until you give me
reason to distrust
i give everybody i have a utmost respect
and reverence
for for people and believe in the
goodness of people and that no one's out
to try and harm me now i'm not foolish
my eyes are open
i could listen to your questions and
maybe i hear you going oh i think rich
is trying to
weasel in here and trying to do
something that's not really true
but until then i'm going no 100 100
trust until you prove me other until you
prove it otherwise
um i have learned and do believe
in this relationship responsibility and
freedom the responsibility of freedom
and the freedom and responsibility of
the choices we make today
that compound assets in our future they
you can t yourself up for more green
lights with the choices we make today
meaning if i don't like cheat and steel
if i choose not to
now i think it's a very selfish act
not to like cheating still and someone
will go wait a minute
it's a selfish act too like cheating
still because you get what you want
right now
yeah is that really selfish though i
don't think so because
if you do that for the rest of your life
everywhere you go you got to look over
your shoulder to make sure no one's
there in the room that you like cheating
stole from so
when you're looking over your shoulder
you're not spending your time you're
spending their time and you're not
present so you're stressed so you really
didn't you really wasn't a selfish act
you
bought debits and yellow lights in your
future not the freedom of green lights
i'm trying to live a life where i don't
leave crumbs
and don't have to look over my shoulder
i don't owe anybody money
you know i don't want to i've i haven't
been perfect but for what i've screwed
up on hopefully i've gone apologize i
made amends and probably still have more
to make that i don't know but
i'm trying to make choices where each
i'm teeing myself up for tomorrow
morning at the very basic level
here's here's a basic green light put
coffee in your coffee filter the night
before so when you get up the neck
tomorrow morning groggy all you gotta do
is push the damn button
because it's hard to make a coffee when
you hadn't had your coffee sometimes
and when you don't put the coffee in the
filter you get up the next one like why
didn't i team myself up for this
why wouldn't i kind of my future self
here well there's choices we make every
day to be kind and cool to our future
selves and the honey hole of those
choices i think which is what i'm
chasing
is where are the where
can we make the choices where what we
want is actually what we need
and what we need is actually what we
want
that seems to be the honey hole of
heaven on earth right there where what's
good for us
selfishly is also what's good for the
most amount of people
that's that's where it's really that's
the ultimate spot i believe
right that i haven't got to but i'm
still chasing it's not
dissimilar from 12 steps i'm i'm in
recovery for a long time and and so much
of
the steps are about like putting through
putting a person through
a program that allows them to you know
make amends for their past behavior
redress their character defects so that
you can
emerge and navigate the world looking
people in the eye
telling the truth not being afraid of
what's you know
your wife's gonna find in your jeans
pockets when she's doing the laundry or
you know just
being able to like live um congruent
like where your actions are in alignment
with your values and you don't have to
look over
you know your shoulder or worry about
like when that lie is going to catch up
to you
yeah i've heard that i've never never
been in or don't really know the 12
steps i've known some people that are in
them
and really enjoy the conversations where
we found a synonymous
sort of approach and view on things um
look man i it's hard to remember a lie
it is
it is it's work man and it's not fun
work to try and make up and
go to every situation going oh wait a
minute who all's involved is there
anyone screwed over here what's the
situation jeez oh man it's stressful
yeah and and me i'm a fan of stress and
people that go no stress i'm like what
are you talking about
you're alive it's a toxic stress that
you carry
yeah it's not the right kind life's hard
enough with that creating
extra work for ourselves that's not
constructive if we're just
running around trying to play defense to
cover up our past mistakes
we're busting our ass dealing with stuff
then something that's not constructive
or affirmatively moving forward
we're going to run into enough hill
uphill battles
without having to deal with you know
sins of our past or or things or
contracts we broke in our past man try
not to gather up too many of them
and you've got more energy to handle the
ones that you the the real battles that
are in front of us anyway
yeah yeah uh the other idea that you
keep circling back to in the book
is this idea of relativity and i'm not
sure i totally
grasp where you're coming from with that
but it keeps it keeps coming up in bold
typeface throughout the book yes so
the tool theory that's come to me is
this when faced with the inevitable
get relative now when do we deem a
situation inevitable
that's already a relative question let's
take covid
right now inevitable it's here
don't deny it don't sit here every day
getting all excited about maybe tomorrow
it's gone because it won't be gone
tomorrow
so how do i get relative with this okay
well for me instant for instance uh
um you know you can persist through a
situation
you can pivot or you can raise the white
flag and say i give to fight another day
well we're in covet so
let's not raise the flag and say we're
going to fight another day because we're
all in it
now can i persist through this doing
living and expecting everything that i
was before covered
yeah i could do that but i don't see the
the the net gain in that because i think
it's going to be around here for a while
so i got to pivot
all right so what i mean by pivot get
relative with this situation
the inevitable code with that rent all
right i'm forced to be at home more i'm
quarantining
don't like that i don't like that but
all right let me start look at the
upside here
uh i'm doing some more inventory on
myself i'm spending more time with my
kids
i'm cooking more with my family in the
kitchen i got my mom with us so the kids
are around their grandmother
more than they ever were and she's 88 so
that's a good thing
um maybe spend some more time writing
right now um
i'm starting to try to find the assets
the green lights in this red light that
written that's how i'm choosing to get
relative with it
that's a choice that we can make with
every situation once we deem it
inevitable now if we endure
if you if you if you deem an outcome of
something you want
if you say well it's an it's inevitable
like i
i i can't get it if you say that too
soon
we're a quitter but if you say it too
late
we're acting out the definition of
insanity trying to bang our head on
while trying to get a different outcome
by doing the same thing
over and over and over and over and over
so we have to measure those things for
ourselves when do we deem a situation
level an outcome
inevitable for us or or by getting it or
not getting it
and then how do we get relative with it
sometimes i need to back off being
so persistent resilient and say i have
to reapproach this the way i'm looking
at this
i got to dance up in a different step i
got to throw myself off balance and
reapproach this circumstance in my life
this question this crossroads um
there's that's a that's an art there
that we're all trying to i think
work out is when to deem something
inevitable and then once we do
how do we get relative with it um
is that a little confusing no i got it i
mean
it reminds me of of the serenity prayer
which is sort of very much you know god
grant me the serenity to accept the
things i cannot change the courage to
change the things i can and
the wisdom to know the difference like
it kind of boils down to that but
i'm wondering like does this come is
this a muscle that you've
flexed for so long that it comes
naturally to you or is there like a
daily practice is gratitude a reflex or
is that something that you have to
cultivate for yourself good question
um look i didn't come you know it was
going back and looking at the 50 years
of my life in the 36 years of diaries
that revealed that understanding when
faced with the inevitable get relative
it wasn't something that i'd written
down or thought over and opined over in
the past and then tried to practice
um look as far as gratitude i will
you know i was raised on you know
if you come into breakfast in a bad mood
mom said get your ass back in your
bedroom and don't come out here till you
see the rose in the vase and said the
dust on the table
i was raised on oh you're griping about
not having any shoes
that right oh yeah you think you got it
so bad well let me introduce you to the
kid with no feet
whoa [ __ ] okay uh talk about relativity
um we were raised on being thankful that
the sun came up another day
and that better be enough for you to be
happy today that better be enough for
you to stand tall because that wasn't a
guarantee so what are you going to do
with it we were raised on
drop down to rock bottom and be thankful
for things that we take for granted
every day
so has that triggered me through life to
maybe see
and be have thanks for certain things
that maybe i should just expect
sure probably yeah um
at the same time you know
uh i've got a pretty i've had a pretty
good threshold
for taking the context of a situation
pretty early in
in circumstance and going all right
what's my risk reward here how do i get
what i want here and is what i want
really what i need
all right what's the long term long
money roi
on the choice i make here am i doing
something uh being eccentric for
eccentricity's sake
oh yeah well there's nothing really
constructive about that that's kind of
not worth
[ __ ] that's a fad uh that's not gonna
last what's a lasting choice that i can
make here that's going to be good for me
and good for the whole situation
uh that i could sleep well with it's not
going to wake me up in the middle of the
night going ah why'd you do that
well i'm not going to wake up tomorrow
morning and go regret it or think it was
a one-off flash in the pan
trying to make choices that are gonna
have long money
um ones that are gonna last one that are
gonna
gonna um feed my good wolf instead of my
bad wolf
you know what i mean um so
a lot of it i think has been instinct
and then i'm just now trying to put it
into words into a
theory that i can go oh remember that
you can apply that
is that situation inevitable when do you
deem it such
and how do you get relative with it so
it was a way of just almost academically
intellectualizing something that maybe
has been an instinct for me
that i noticed in looking at my diaries
and how i got out of situations and
turned some red lights into some green
lights
so it's not a function of every day i
get up and at this time this is when i
sit down and journal
and i actively try to you know make a
gratitude list or anything like that
it's not it's it's a more
ephemeral kind of thing no it's more of
a i'm not a
it's more of a uh um you know i like to
say
this way you know i've been working on
this for about four years now
no audition it's live you're in the
movie
it's all happening life is the movie you
wake up
it's all the record button is always on
it's always on so when inspired do it
we don't have to preparation preparation
what well it's live
go now do it quit talking about it i
mean work it out
a lot of times being live is preparing
i'm a big preparer for roles and work
and preparing for things but trying to
look at is like
i mean i've also had times my life where
i sat there and prepared prepared
prepare prepare prepared looked up and
three years later i'm like
you never got in the game you're still
preparing dude what are you doing go go
what are you so afraid of failing hop in
the game of life
you know or so so yeah it's more of a uh
it's more of been an instinct that i'm
just now sort of defining
one of the things that you say in the
book that that is really
stuck with me i mean i highlighted a
bunch of stuff but this is the one that
really stood out to me the most
is this idea of being less impressed and
more involved
yes i love that and it's so concisely
put
and it's profound because it applies to
so many things like
less impressed with yourself less
impressed with other people not trying
to chase
other people's ideas of what you should
could need to be
trying to find your moral center and the
way to the path to that
is to immerse yourself to to give of
yourself in service to others but to be
involved in your community
to you know engage with the world in
you know a deeper way and engage with
yourself in a deeper way
i mean if i
have a reverence for you rich right now
oh my god
[ __ ] i i got kind of dude do you know
how long about want to talk to you man i
just think you're like that
you i'm fighting it right now dude i'm
so happy to be talking to you and it's
like i
the people pleaser in me is what i'm
trying to keep at bay so i can just be
present and involved in this
conversation well
if you succumb to that and you were
going to go
people please you wouldn't be if you
were overly impressed with me you
wouldn't be involved
in this conversation to the extent that
you can be just like if i had that
reference for you tuna
that you were above mortality for me i
couldn't actually be giving
my true self to you in this conversation
because i'm removed from it
so if i have a reference i noticed it
was soon after my father died when this
came to me
fame money people that i was like wow
uh my dad's passing gave me the gift to
go no
all mortal things better look at them at
eye level
at the same time the underbelly of that
is all the things you're patronizing
mcconaughey
and looking down on and condescending
and sloughing off is not worthy
rose up to eye level and the world was
flat
i could see wider further and more
clearly and i stood up straighter i was
a half inch taller and looked at me and
go
welcome to the rodeo buddy time to get
get on the bull
you know quit relying on dad to make
sure he's got your back if you fall off
that was part of being so it happens
you know and so how do i do that how do
we do that
with full respect i have full respect
for you
you can have full respect for me but now
we can still be involved in the
conversation
because if one person is on the pedestal
above humanity and mortality you can't
be involved with it
and it's not even fair to that person it
happens in relationships
you'll see somebody in a relationship
and i've been in them
where a female thinks i'm superman and i
think she's wonder woman
well that relationship ain't gonna go
too far right
because we're both holding each other on
an unlivable expectation
of a pedestal neither one of us can live
up to it and we're neither one of us are
really involved with each other humanly
because we have such reverence for the
other projections
um so i don't mean any lack of respect
and i don't have less respect actually
more respect but respect is a more
mortal understanding
to iraq you and i can engage but if i
have too much of a reverence for you or
anyone else i can't really be involved
with them
and they can't be involved with me
mm-hmm so if the
if the if the tables turn so that's what
that lesson press more involved is
um you know it's a bit of the you know
the eye in the sky when you're in the
when they're in the palm and the hand of
god or the cradle of
when you when you think you've got it uh
all figured out go to that
google map pov and look at this little
bitty dot on this spinning planet called
earth and this whole thousands of years
that the tans of time move
and you notice how meaningless you are
and we look at it we go oh geez none of
it matters
which is a very liberating feeling oh
good takes the pressure off geez none of
it matters
but at that same time what has happened
to me is i've gone oh
and that's exactly why it all matters
oh here we go now we're on the bull now
we're riding
you know just when i saw how little i
mattered is is usually when it's come to
me how much
it all matters well there's a humility
in that
right and i think humility is hard to
come by for
for everybody in certain times
throughout their life
but you know for somebody who kind of
exists in the world
at this strange uh
you know level of stratosphere um
how do you like the connection to that
kind of humility so that you can be
involved in the world i mean is that
you always seem to carry yourself with
that and you've never
not had that and i have to imagine that
part of that is because you've made this
choice to you know be in the world in a
certain way whether it's
you know at the rv park or you know
on the amazon or you know wrestling in
africa
with that like that keeps you grounded
and level-headed about you know who you
are and where you where you sit
you know in the grand scheme of
everything yeah well also some of those
experiences i've had
have been better than fiction for me you
know what i mean
some of those stories i'm like oh geez
if hollywood wrote this no one would
believe it
you know so they were more extraordinary
in ways to me at the time
um you know humility
that's a that's been a word that i've
wrestled with
all my life because for so long i had
the wrong definition of it
humility to be humbled humility we all
say
have humility but no one likes to be
humiliated
oh wait a minute what's the nexus of
that word how can i be humble but still
confident how can i be humble but still
have identity
it wasn't until a few years ago and i
think this definition came i think it's
jordan peterson
um the definition of humility which i i
do purchase which is it's admitting you
have more learn
um and that definition i lose no
confidence
or lose no identity in but i'm very
quick to go
yep i got more to learn now if i can
call that humility
and go into the world every day going i
know i have more to learn
i can move confidently with that
humility
and be humble but boy my early
definitions of humility in
my mind were almost arrogant false
modesty oh no no no no that don't
i don't know you know and i remember
this i'm gonna tell you that this was a
i've harked back to this
moment in high school there's a girl
renis sherman
and i remember i showed up to school one
day i was a junior
and she was a friend she was a friend of
mine we never dated she was just a
friend she goes
she's coming she goes you know what
matthew mcconaughey you are a handsome
man
and i went oh come on no no renee's
telling that and she grabbed my hand
sternly and look at me and she goes
don't you dare give me that i don't no
no no no no she because you know what
you need to do when someone gives you a
compliment like that that's true i go
what she goes
say thank you and i remember going oh
oh wow oh okay and it hit me
but i didn't learn really how to live
and understand humility it was always
almost a regressive field it's like the
word vulnerability
i'm still wrestling with what that word
means um and how to feel still feel
empowered in that part of what i've come
up with that
that it helps me understand that my
relationship with the word humility and
vulnerability is that like
i know i want to be in the know i love
being in the know
but i'm still learning to be in the know
is also knowing what you don't know
i want to know what i don't know so
that's another version of understanding
the definition of humility for me that
it feels like it empowers me
but still has me be humble well a close
cousin of that
those ideas humility vulnerability is
is authenticity and you know your arc
and your journey is very much one of
you know trying to get closer to who the
authentic matthew
is at least that's what i got out of the
book um
and i think a really powerful kind of
illustrious illustrative
example of that is the macona sense
itself can we talk about that a little
bit sure
because it's such an epic pivot you know
which is another theme in your book
um i don't know if this is a spoiler but
you
you uh admit in the book that you're the
one who actually came up with that word
yes which i would not have thought
so that's that's being vulnerable to
admit that you're the one who who
who crafted that and then like that's
the one piece of the book that my wife's
telling yeah
did you really need to put that in there
i'm gonna sound so arrogant i was like
no
i thought it was great i'm like i'm
admitting it you know
i admitted it it was look i felt i was
aware enough at the time that i've
running a few uh on a run of a few films
that were that
had their you know relative hits and and
made their mark and i was getting some
you know adulation
and people people in the interviews were
going man you're really on a great run
here
really on a great and it came to me that
this term like you're on this great run
you're on the street running and i was
in i think tell your ride
or one of those film festivals and i
said
being a lover of bumper stickers and
slogans i was like i gotta give this
like an album i gotta give this like a
title of an album here you know this
sounds this little movement i'm on that
people were saying i'm on so i was like
mcconaughson's i said well i can't come
forward and say
yeah i call it the because but
in this interview and i thought about it
just at the moment
the guy went on the interview was going
yeah and you've been on this run whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa you've been i was
like yeah i was talking to a reporter
the other day and he actually called it
a mcconnaissance
and he goes a mcconaughey yeah he goes
oh that's great i love it my
connoisseurs you like that i'm like yeah
i mean shoot he said it sounded like
comes off the tongue pretty easy sounds
pretty cool to say i'm with it
well he wrote that and then it picked
out people started calling it mcconaugh
science
and i just kind of went with it and so
then in the book i decided to say you
know what i'm the one who planted that
seed
i love that i think that's hilarious man
but what's what's amazing about it
everybody knows the story they know the
movies you were doing and then the
movies you ultimately ended up doing
um but that period i what i didn't
realize
was how much intention and mindfulness
went into making that pivot that it
wasn't
um first of all it went on longer than i
thought and then also
that it was very much planned like if i
can't do
things that interest me that intrigue me
as an artist and as a human being like
i'm gonna
i'm gonna opt out purposefully
and be willing to suffer the
consequences
of not making any income and having your
wife
you know by your side for that period of
time now you know
you had it's not like you couldn't put
food on the table but still
it's scary you know in hollywood to
suddenly say i'm not going to do that
are you going to be obsolete will you
ever work again and
you went through you know a really
extended period of time where it wasn't
clear
that you were ever gonna make your way
back no it wasn't
and i didn't know how long the sort of
sabbatical drought would go on and
i shed many a tear on my wife's shoulder
uh
one with
what i what i was getting from my career
what i wasn't getting for my career
um i was rolling with rom-coms at the
time
i was rom-com mcconaughey
shirtless on the beach and i looked that
in the eye and still do and go you damn
right i was and those rom-coms paid rent
for those houses that i had on the beach
where i went
shirts guilty fact
i remember seeing you on the beach one
time in mount i think you were renting a
house with lance
for a period of time yeah yeah i
remember that
i was running down the beach and i saw
you guys out there
yes indeed um
so but i looked at my life
and i remember i just had a newborn
camilla and i just had levi
and so the one thing i knew i always
wanted to be is a father now come true
and my life was full man my life was so
vital i would
had had i had more rage i had more joy i
had more happiness i laughed louder i
cried harder
it was just my life the ceiling in the
basement of my emotions were full
in my life but my work
was like uh another rom-com i love doing
these but
oh there's a new script i think i could
do that tomorrow morning i think i could
wake up and do that and i was like
well that's not bad but geez i want i
sure would like to do some work that
scares me in the right way
that makes me go
i'm not sure what i'm going to do with
this role but this is going to be an
experience and i wasn't getting those
roles so
yes i couldn't the roles i wanted to do
were not being offered
so because i couldn't do what i wanted
to do i stopped doing what i was doing
and i remember i called my money mentor
how to do with my money you've invested
well
okay good because i'm about to take off
work and i don't know when i'll get work
again
call my agent i talked to camilla about
it and she said she repeated my dad's
words to me you know okay if we're gonna
do this
don't half-ass it we're gonna you're
gonna do it
so i said no more homecomings well
nothing came in nothing was offered
except rom-coms for the first six months
after that and i have that you know how
puritanical was i
i had that great little story about
getting an 8 million
offer for a rom-com and reading it and
going
it's a good script but no thank you then
they came back and offered me 10 million
dollars i said
no thank you then they offered 12.5
million dollars and i said
ellipsis ellipsis ellipsis
no thank you then they came back at 14.5
you know what i said let me read that
script again
i mean i read that again and you know
what
it was better written than the original
one
that a million dollar offer it was had
more angles i saw more opportunities i
saw more ways i could make it work
it mind you it was the exact same words
as the original script but that offer
it was a better written script but i
said no
and then that sort of seemed to get the
signal across hollywood
he's not bluffing he's really not doing
any rom-coms or action comedies right
now
so what came in for the next year
nothing
nothing i mean i checked in with my
agent every couple weeks but it was
basically like
nothing your persona not persona non
grata nothing's coming in for you
now we're 20 min 20 months into the
sabbatical
i'm in texas you haven't seen me in a
rom-com you haven't seen me share this
on the beach everything that you
expected to see me in that i would
sort of pigeonholed me into only being
that and not considered for other roles
20 months into that all of a sudden what
i think happened is
some producers and directors in
hollywood went
you know be an interesting to cast for
this role
in killer joe paperboy mud
magic mike true detective dallas buyers
club
you know would be an interesting choice
a novel choice
mcconaughey but i would not have been a
novel choice for those things
20 months earlier right so the way i
look at it is that was an
unbranding time for me again back to
process of elimination i couldn't do
what i wanted to do so i just said i had
to eliminate what i didn't want to do
anymore
and i unbranded for 20 months no one
knew where i was
and i wasn't also i also was not in your
household or on your tv screen
in your theater being what you had
expected me to be
and so all of a sudden i became a new
good idea right and
um that was a yeah that was a sacrifice
and i didn't know when that damn thing
was going to end or if it was and i
entertained different career paths i
entertained getting out of
the entertainment industry all together
i thought i might go be a fourth grade
teacher i thought i might be a
a high school football coach uh
wow you did seriously you really d
that's that's hard to believe you really
were doing that
yeah wow i i thought i might get back
into law
um i i considered you know
being an orchestral conductor
um well there's a couple lessons in that
i mean one is
uh back to this idea of of magnetizing
the green light
like ultimately and and the second being
you know saying no in order to get the
yes right like you had to do
there was this palette cleanser that
hollywood had to endure
to get to the point where suddenly
you were a good idea when you weren't
before and that required you to say
no i mean i don't know how many people
you know have the gumption to say no to
15 million dollars to do
a movie for a couple months ultimately
it pays off
and it shows the power of that but it
takes a lot of fortitude
and conviction to commit to something
like that
and faith and belief to foresee
that at some point it's going to pay off
yeah well you look at the australian
story when i was an exchange student for
a year
uh i couldn't even believe that story
it's
all true have you have you gotten back
in touch with that family
yeah every time i do australian press
they usually show up
on screen my god
and you know that year
you know before i went on that year the
rotary club who sponsored me
wanted me to sign the contract to say i
won't come home until the full year's
done
and i said no what do you want me to
sign that for i'm going for a year and
they go no that's what everybody says
but you're going to get homesick you
want to want to come home and i said no
you know what i'll shake your hand on it
but i'm not signing that thing
well they agreed on a handshake and i
agreed on a handshake well trust me you
read that year
there are many times i had full good
reason to get the hell out of dodge and
come back home but i was like no man i'm
in this
i've got to finish it out there's
something in this for me
there's a green light in this hardship
experience that i'm going through this
insanity i'm going through there's a
reason for it so stick with it don't
pull the parachute
well same thing with uh um you know this
the sabbatical of of not working
once i was in it i was like i'm not
going i'm not i'm in
i almost gained more confidence as i
went going
no this is getting gnarlier but every
day you're not getting it's getting
oh you're in it now mcconaughey this is
this is this is
upside down and backwards stick with it
there's really something good going to
come at us so
when those jobs did come that i wanted
to do i was ferocious on those things
i i mean i my fangs were long and i
chewed
them up and went hardcore into them um
so yeah it was by saying no um and i
have
you know there's great prudence and
sticking through
sticking with resistance you know i mean
look
let's talk about this with this time
we're in
i wish code was gone tomorrow which
would have never been here
so i want to preface this next thing i
say with that
but as a people individuals in a society
is there value in it to ourselves even
though we will have more tragedies and
even losses of life
is there more will we have a greater
value and understanding of a green light
in the future if we're in it for longer
because we paid the penance longer
because we were stripped to our
necessities longer
because we went through this resistance
longer and we were pulling our hair out
of our head so when we come out of it we
don't just snap back to right where we
were before
because we're us humans are tricky man
we
we we can say we go through change we
intellectually talk about it
but boy we go right back to old habits
like that
even bad habits we go back to them and
so
unless it's the consequences are enough
or they unrest
or the disruption and goes on long
enough for us to go
no my floor has literally been moved i
am
changing my priorities about what i
value in life because of this hardship
it has to go on things we we're we're
sort of
our muscle memory switches goes right
back to where we used to be pretty
quickly
unless it's a long enough penance to pay
you can't be
the phoenix unless you burn you got to
burn
first you gotta burn god and it's got to
be in in
like it's got to burn you got to look
down and you got to find it's a lot of
times we have to be
scarred not like ooh that was hot and
not like oh it left a little black mark
like oh [ __ ]
no i got a scar that's their flight from
getting burned oh well now
i'm really making the change i mean
we're we're
we're uh uh what's the word uh
we're hard headed like that you know
what i mean
as people we again we intellectualize
that oh these things change but
very quickly quickly we revert right
back to our old habits even if they're
bad ones
unless the penance has gone on for a
long enough time
yeah there's always opportunities in
these in these
setbacks and in this moment of forced
repose
you know amongst the economic challenges
and
everything that so many people are
enduring right now there's the general
discomfort
of being still with oneself that's so
difficult right like this mirror is up
in front of us
and it's forcing us to reckon with how
we're living our lives because
we can't move right now we have to be
in that discomfort and it's debilitating
for a lot of people but if you can
open your aperture to it there's so much
to be
learned from that and you don't have to
go to the amazon
we're stuck at home on zoom but we have
that opportunity
open your aperture too we are in a
forced winter
right now and many of us including me
needed to take one ourselves anyway
well now it's taking agai we all got the
permit we're all on it we got our forced
winter it's
forced time to be introspective time to
do inventory whether you want to or not
strip down the necessities what do we
got how do i navigate who am i
oh i can't go anywhere well what's one
of our you know
part of pulling the parachute is well i
need to go out i'm going out
going out to dinner we're gonna go come
on let's go get together okay
it's there's some prudence and being
forced with ourselves and hopefully
we're taking
enough of us can take the opportunity
that's there in that
to evolve yeah yeah how do you feel
about this you know later chapter in the
reconnaissance
of you becoming like this guru you know
this person
of wisdom that i don't know when it
began maybe it began when you gave that
commencement speech but at some point
you kind of went from matthew the actor
into somebody who you know was
was basically imparting life lessons to
the world
like how do you think about that or how
do you feel about that was that
intentional or is it just a byproduct of
of who you are i think it started off
more of a byproduct and then
has gained some intention along the way
um you know to go back to that
uh it's live we're all on the show
the recording the camera's always
recording you know and uh
and to say ask myself
are you making legacy choices for
yourself right now mcconaughey are you
living in a way live that is useful for
yourself and others
um look i'll say this i go back to
university of texas
and i had an idea for this
script to screen class as a professor
but in my mind i'm still like i'm
talking to students i feel like i was
there the other day
but then i start sharing things with
them and they're going like whoa that's
awesome
thank you for telling me that i'm like
oh that wasn't obvious and i'm like no
we didn't know that and so i started to
go wait a minute
you got 28 years of experience of acting
and being on sets matthew
oh geez that's right add that up you do
have some experience
that may be innate to you now that is
novel
to a student so you do have something to
share some experience to share that
maybe someone else didn't have
um i you know
dip sharing this this book has got quite
a few tools in it for
how to find our frequency individually
and hopefully as a collective
we're going through a time right now
great distrust we don't know what to
believe in you don't just
trust others you all of a sudden you
look up you don't trust yourself and
that
little revolution can go back and forth
well now i don't trust myself now i
really don't trust you
uh now i don't believe in myself now i
don't don't believe in anything and
those are dead end streets uh ultimately
so
how do we rebuild some trust i think
it's through values i think values are
bipartisan non-denominational i think
those are the solid stepping stones that
we need to each look in the mirror and
ask ourselves so we can be better
out on a daily basis and that'll be
incremental steps out of this time
into hopefully a more evolved state that
we can get out of
and help us look back at 2020 as an
actual red banner year
of recreation and recreation and and a
new beginning
um i try to share what i know i also try
to show what i don't know i share
questions
a lot um people for instance come to me
a lot about oh they love the fouchy dr
fauci interview i did right
i didn't reveal anything novel in that i
like everybody was just saying like
can i get a bullet point sheet on the
tudos and the not to do's and can you
just say them for me real clearly
because
there's no consensus here man and can
you see me not that not the long version
and just a short
yes no do this don't do that and so i
just went on a rapid fire with him and
didn't ask questions that had not been
brought up
they just hadn't been sort of for a lot
of people hadn't been brought up in a
succinct way
so i said you know do i have a platform
where maybe someone else already knows
that information but maybe i got a
platform where someone else is going to
hear it maybe listen to me in a way they
wouldn't listen to someone else
or maybe they didn't hear right yeah
well let's go have those conversations
um the minister of culture work i'm
doing right now is a lot based on that
and that's me you know saying i'm
stepping into playing
my favorite character that's me saying
go play you
in the character of you and like the
things that wake you up at two in the
morning that i've been writing down in
my diary since i was 14.
it's always about culture about how do
we get along what's our individual
responsibilities how do we get to
freedom how are we responsible for
freedom and how does freedom have its
responsibilities
what should i expect of you what should
you expect of me
can we have a social contract here as
humans you know because right now our
social contracts are broke right
um where are my person why why are they
broke well partially maybe i broke my
own social contract
maybe i've let myself slide on things
and to go out and act like i have a
social contract with you
i'm just acting like one and not being
one well wait a minute i'm not gonna let
that pass i gotta be
one i need to be one that voluntary
obligation we need to make voluntary
pledges with ourselves so what we expect
of ourselves
so we can expect it from others and if
we get that reciprocity going
then enough of us do that then we
collectively make change
the other idea is this we gotta remember
we're never gonna arrive
there's not a destination i don't
you know i it's it's it's like
our lives and say america the langston
hughes point
america yet that's
what should we we should be chasing yet
we never get there with the social the
cultural revolution we're going
we're not going to get to perfect
justice
but if we can make an incremental
ascension forward that's it stay in the
race commit to the chase
and with ourselves can we just keep
chasing our better selves
a little bit and now we're going to
screw up a long way can america just
keep we're an aspiration our lives are
an aspiration america is an aspiration
it's a chasing of yet um and i think
that's what
we ultimately are is is individuals
we're all
should be we all should be chasing
ourselves what more fun wild adventurous
thing to chase in your life than
yourself
well there's a there's an unbridled
optimism to that that's infectious
and that i love uh and i don't want to
take up too much of your time we can
we can end it on this you know i can't
let you go without
digging a little bit more deeply into
kind of where we're at in this american
experiment right now we're headed into
an election
we are extremely divided communities
families
individuals are having difficulty
finding common ground being able to
even effectively communicate and there
is this
um you know layer of of whether it's
fake news or misinformation that's
confusing people
and driving us apart and i have this
sense of us
fracturing and i'm trying to figure out
how to get my hands around it how i can
communicate with my brothers and my
sisters how i can be
more empathetic like how can we look to
what unites us to our commonalities
which are so much more robust than
the details that might divide us on
paper or on social media
but i find myself concerned about what
i'm seeing
and where we're heading so how do we how
do we write the ship
matthew great question solve
this problem for me and for us
oh wow yeah right um you know so i met
earlier yeah it is times of great
distrust
uh and others in ourselves our social
contracts are broken our personal
contracts are broken
we don't have expectations of ourselves
or others right now the private sector
down to the individual has more power
than ever
we can't trust our leadership politics
is a broken business
uh what do we want people wanting
security well we're all individuals wait
a minute what's where's the collective
uh it's a we gotta we gotta
all this is being politicized along the
way the body counts are being added up
for which side of the
which side of the aisle wants to win
that's the only numbers each side it's
counting
um we got an election year are we gonna
have a civil war
man can we just get to january 2021
which is a symbolic day
but nothing more than a symbolic day
do we have a 10-year restoration do we
have a 20-year restoration
i don't know how long it'll go what can
we rely on
uh empathy one thing a little amnesty
right now it's a tough time for
everybody
i don't know how to make a collective
change i don't know how to make an
overall systemic
change or a law i don't think people
want to be legislated like that i think
it
again comes down to each one of us need
to look in the mirror
and go how can i be a little bit better
what can i do a little bit better
alright be great i want to be perfect
there is no best i can be a little bit
better
how can be a little more fair how can i
understand that my brother and sister
are also hurting maybe in more in
different ways than i
am how can i have a conversation without
a condemnation
how can i have more patience to take a
breath and listen
and let someone who hasn't been heard
speak more loudly than maybe they need
to
but but hear them how do we make this
time
not just a flash in the pan uh how do
how do we be honest with the choices we
make for ourselves
selfishly are also the best choices for
the most amount of people
and then there's not any specific recipe
for that but take that into
consideration when we make our choices
for ourselves
um again responsibility and freedom
we're gonna have to build our way out of
this time we're gonna have to break a
damn sweat
for a while and i think we have to have
that long
view that feeling like this is going to
go on for a while now how can we make
that a part of our daily
instincts of how we go about our lives
how do we treat ourselves how do we
treat our loved ones how do we treat our
employees how do we treat people we work
with
how do we treat what we're building and
what are we are we just for profit or
are we for purpose as well uh what's our
purpose
i'm not interested in politics i'm
interested in some purpose though
politics is a broken business i don't
know who to trust so that's what i mean
by the private sector down to the
individual
you have more power right now to define
your future than ever
um because you actually don't have
anywhere anyone else up there no
institutions to rely on
for that guidance so understand it man
some of us are going
what the hell man give me a map i don't
know what to trust in i don't know
what's a consensus here
um some of us are going to do well right
now
because we can just keep our head above
water just try and make it through this
time it's going to pass we're going to
be moving forward
we are not turning the page yet though
when the time comes to turn the page on
covid when the time comes to turn the
page on the cultural revolution
the only way it's going to work is that
the collective
all of us every color everyone you've
got code if you don't every color of
skin
do it together to some form or fashion
i think you know as much as we
are a nation of individuals and love our
individualism
we are failing at
any sort of collective responsibility
we have failed with the mask of seeing
that as a civic
duty instead of a damn don't you tell me
what to do
[ __ ] it's it's the wrong kind of
selfish
it's actually not a selfish move to to
to fight those
fights there is a responsibility that we
can choose
to take for and with each other and
ourselves and those two are not
exclusive
my hunch is that lies and values my
hunch is it lies in
responsibility accountability
risk-taking sense of humor
uh the list goes on and on and on that
we can just be a little kinder a little
more fair
a little more empathetic a little more
understanding a little more forgiving
also
holding on accountability no no this
isn't gonna be a free ride
i'm not in for a world kumbaya no we
gotta
it's gonna take work and the greatest
thing about america is
when america is working right is
if you're willing to work at something
and educate yourself and go after
something
you more so than anywhere else should
have the opportunity
to achieve that but not without the work
and the education and the hustle to go
do it
so you know i'd say this man start off
with trying to create more green lights
for yourself
and others and see where those two meet
and see that actually being selfless
is actually a very selfish act creating
more for others is actually very selfish
for yourself as well
and make sure you're trying to make sure
your selfish choices for yourself also
light the way for more people as well
boom beautifully put thank you man that
was incredible
i appreciate your time today i enjoyed
it super fun man
thank you uh the book is incredible
green lights available everywhere
october 20 is the day
that's right october 20th this year um
you've been
attacking this thing like it's the
release of a blockbuster movie
like all you you've been out there man
like this is going
big and wide i can tell already well
that's i'm approaching it look
this is the most truest permanent
extension of me
that i've ever been a part of and to
whatever extent i'm i'm i'm honored with
that
and and i and i want to it's it's it's
the first time
you know if i look at like a movie which
i have
i wrote it i directed it i edited it
you know what i mean i i did it yeah so
i'm not
acting in someone else's script being
directed by someone else so it's the
truest
permanent extension of me that i've ever
put out and
that's scary and fun and all those
things and yes i had to have my chin
strap on and my mouth guard in while i
was writing it but
[Laughter]
well you did an incredible job i i love
the book i read it
in like just two sittings um it's super
enjoyable and i think it's gonna a lot i
think it's really
it's gonna help a lot of people too it's
gonna help a lot of people
i i hope so that'd be great cool
um all right hope to meet you in person
one day but until then
uh best of luck with everything yeah at
some point hopefully we'll we'll go do
that trip with dan
good deal thanks dude i appreciate it
man best of luck
right on peace
[Music]
you